this is my my little girl
with her hair that she said kept growing
out rather than down which is how she
wanted it to grow this is the princess
card that was created because i couldn't
find it in the stores
[Music]
motherhood launched my life in many ways
certainly launched my career i was
looking for a card for my little girl
who was seven and going through this
stage where she she didn't like her hair
and i went looking for a greeting card
that would just kind of subtly reinforce
her sense of self
and i thought oh i'll find a brown
brown-skinned princess
and realized quickly that there was a
complete absence of anything that was
representative
and
had one of those epiphany moments where
i thought oh why don't i do this rather
than discarding the thought i stepped
into it and it changed my life because
it opened up this entire entrepreneurial
journey
where i realized the power of doing
something which is driven by meaning
colorblind cards went on to be really
the first independent publisher to
secure a presence for black cards or
multicultural cards in the british high
street
we won lots of awards and
got distributed in america and south
africa and started this almost certainly
part of this early conversation around
why representation and diversity and
inclusion are so important in retail
very proud of that
when i wake up i pick up my pad and my
pen and i just let the stream of
consciousness hit the page before i
start my day and it's an opportunity to
check in with myself
and sometimes it's ideas
and sometimes it's just a sort of really
tired really tired need tea you know i
find by the end of this three pages of
writing i'm centered and so i'm able to
step into my day really knowing how i'm
feeling and sometimes i have answers to
problems which is is just brilliant so
yeah i highly recommend it
[Music]
i think it's very important to stop
apologizing and it can be difficult it
can be really difficult because we live
in a world where you know often we're
programmed to feel like there is a
certain way we should be
a certain way we should behave a certain
way we should look when actually
what we have to offer our you know our
unique point of difference is all about
who we are because i will always be a
woman who grew up on a council estate
who
you know is very aware and has family
and friends who are
experiencing or have experienced the
challenges which are a reality for
people of color are a reality for people
from lower socioeconomic backgrounds and
i'm proud of that
because
all of it has contributed to my unique
perspective and my unique experience of
the world and
that's what makes me who i am
two and a half years ago my dad had been
diagnosed with terminal cancer and we
were very close for the first time
really in my professional life i stopped
doing
you know those things that had felt
so critical and had held so much
importance
were put into perspective and i guess it
just sort of drove home
how important it is for us to sometimes
get off the treadmill
[Music]
so what i do is i go on a date with
myself now which is a two-hour period
where it's just me no distractions of
phones or schedules and just a chance
just to kind of be with myself and and
be present and i'm still ambitious i'm
still you know that can be it's just
driven by something that's much more
healthy and that that's that inspires me
on a daily basis
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video